I think one of the keys for me getting
through the season of full-time job to
full-time YouTube Creator was
procrastinating on purpose was at some
level probably to the frustration of
friends and family members many who
would probably say this is just how you
are based on your personality but was
just like literally getting clear on the
one two three four priorities in my life
and ignoring everything else which is
tough I mean that's up to you and it's
just like but it's like people are
texting you people are asking for things
people are emailing things like just
ignoring it people are reaching out
interruptions are happening just
ignoring it you should not be imitating
this is probably another tip you should
not be imitating the activities of a
Creator like me
in this season you should be imitating
the activities of a Creator like me back
when I had the full-time job I'm just
gonna do what Sean's doing well Sean's
got 20 people helping him and so it's
not that this this is just as possible
because the pessimists and Senate goes
oh there's the secret no no no no bro
relax Trevor the Ultimate key is that I
had certain activities and a level of
discipline when I was by myself the only
person working on this editing shooting
doing all the things and I had to
procrastinate on purpose and ignore
anything that wasn't Mission critical
what's just not important at all it's
not even important just not Mission
critical it's like not even important at
all a lot of people do tasks that are
just an absolute waste of your time for
example a dead Facebook page or just a
Facebook page that isn't active even
worse back to the pet peeve people go
the only thing on their Facebook feed is
also why it's not working is links to
their YouTube video well the reach is so
throttled there's literally zero likes
and zero comments and you just do it as
like a discipline that activity has a
net neg it's just not important at all
especially right now but even more so
this could be TV partying video games
procrastinating Leisure it could be
people that steal your energy and weaken
your vision like just
things that are not going to help you
get towards your goals and this is the
law of sacrifice you got to give up to
go up those who figure this out it's
possible but it is it's not that it's
easy it does take discipline it's a
whole other person I wanna I wanna
encourage you it takes a whole lot of
energy and grit to work all day and
spend your energy all day at work and to
get home and to want to work on your
side hustle it's freaking it's so hard
you gotta reset your energy get into the
Zone take a break eat dinner and get
back to the grind and do it over and
over and over again it's hard but it is
possible and so the level of scrupulous
detail you want to have in eliminating
things from your schedule what's Mission
critical what's important but not
Mission critical and what's not
important